blödmann sorry mein name ist luca und
meine lieben freunde gestern bei
valentinstag dahinter stehen sogar noch
blumen sind meine blumen peter spilok
history es sollen heute allerdings nicht
um valentinstag liebe und blumen und was
weiß ich alles gehen sondern ihr seht es
bereits im titel eingeblendet wir
spielen heute ein spiel was sie besser
das bin ich und meine waffe dieses spiel
high stakes legends damit kriegt man
direkt auf bereit und auf spielersuche
dieses spiel ist ein neues spiel von
electronic arts und es soll besser sein
als fortnight und das sagt nicht nur der
herr gespielt sondern wirklich jeder
streamer gerade ninja tief sogar monte
obwohl montes meinung ja auch echt oft
ein bisschen komisch ist jeder sagt auf
jeden fall dass dieses spiel besser sein
soll als fortnight weil es ein paar neue
funktionen zu bringen da als dies
hinzufügt dass keine ahnung was daran
besser sein soll weil ich den vorteil
auch schon über beschissen war auf jeden
fall ist es auch so ein battle royale
spiel also man ist hier auf einer
komplett offenen web es ist allerdings
ein bisschen anders als fordert gerade
von der grafik und von der ganzen web
aufteilung
das hier ist mein skript die jungs ich
bin auf dem dach ich komme sofort runter
hat man landet irgendwo auf der map und
muss sich erstmal waffe so oh mein gott
das ist ja das ist das ist ein gegner
stark luca kommt erster klein nein ich
bin total ich werd ich werde wieder
belebt danke kann ich mich irgendwie
bedanken
ich bin schon wieder tot
also irgendwie ist unser squad nicht das
allerbeste die tür zu nehmen nun können
wir allein tot sei
leute macht immer euer ding ich geh mal
zu meinen freunden hier also das spiel
soll auf jeden fall besser sein als
schneit battle royale
ich war ein ford hat schon echt scheiße
deswegen bald jeden die auch nicht ob
ich hier ist das ein jäger bis zum
gegner
gegner ist dies bei mir ich brauche auf
jeden fall erstmal eine waffe das ist
ein gegner die meisten gegner dich
kritisch alter ich würde am liebsten ein
bisschen anders kommentieren gerade aber
es geht die ganze zeit schon mega ab
dass hier sind gegner die wir leben sich
gerade gegen denn da kann ich da mal
wieso sterben hier nicht ich bin ich
will schon wieder tot
ok hat spaß gemacht ich bin auch gar
nicht tot abzeichen werden steht unten
links jetzt gerade bei meinem namen das
heißt die spieler die in meinem team
sind in meinem squad die können jetzt
meinen sack aufheben und können mich
mehr oder weniger retten
ich glaube aber also er läuft gerade zum
beispiel von meinem grab weg ich glaube
die haben eher weniger bock auf mich ja
egal was ist deine mission hier beide
sind tot und du machst du dein eigenes
ding 2000 jahre später
jawohl das andere abschied willst du uns
vielleicht erst mal retten respawn
zeitüberschreitung kann jetzt bin ich
komplett wahrscheinlich meine
teamkollegen haben 18 und 20 und dann
gibt es noch nicht ich habe null kills
bisher insgesamt wunsch also ich weiß
nicht was an diesem spiel so viel besser
sein soll als ein vorteil ich bin
fordert geiger schlag mal vor dass wir
hier hingehen
die anderen können jetzt auch
vorschlagen wo wir hingehen was sagen
wie gesagt es ist mein erstes match
gerade wenn wir mal ein zweites match
situationen angekommen leute lasst mir
auch irgendeine scheiß waffe bitte ich
habe jetzt einfach irgendwas auch okay
ich habe eine waffe mal schauen ob hier
irgendwo gegner sind ich mache die tür
offen du bist tot
die lappen
kann ich eine treppe bauen.de wand
häuser komm her du kleine räume da
bisher ja ich bin ich bin verblutet ja
das war wieder ein hammerspiel ist ihr
was ich gebe jetzt ein fig darauf wo
meine teamkollegen rau springe ich mein
eigenes ding also da unten fliegen meine
sportkollegen hin dass jetzt eine
allgemeine ganzen leute wir haben noch
wie viele sekunden raus zu springen
keine ahnung ich werde auf jeden fall
jetzt gibt auch eine map ich geh jetzt
mal da hin wo nichts los und zwar
einfach genau hierhin also los gehts
freunde wäre rasen mit voll karacho hier
runter als kurt sich da die ganze zeit
auf jeden fall komisch das so grüner
dampfer aus meinem typen hinten
rauskommt aber ich blicke jetzt auf
jeden fall mal hierhin ach du scheiße
was passiert mit mir
wo soll ich hin ich habe noch voller
leben wenn ich hier in die karre
einsteigen geht das nicht kann ich drauf
hab cool bin ich drauf klasse liegen
hier irgendwo waffen also ich bin jetzt
ganz auf mich allein gestellt das heißt
sie entdecken jetzt erst mal das spiel
kann ich hier wie in minecraft sondern
ein bisschen holz
ach leute es gibt doch eine zone das ist
ja der sinn eines battle royale spiels
also dass ganz viele leute raus springen
anders sind und die zone kleiner und man
wird auf sich allein gesetzte mehr oder
weniger man sich allein gestellt
deutsche sprache schwere sprache dass
sie sind auf jeden fall so supply
container und da sind sachen drin und
die sind bisher nicht beschissen
sehr gut ich kann q drücken um eine
heilbronner aufzustellen heißt passiert
irgendwas hallo kann ich jetzt was
bringt dieses fliegende etwas jetzt kann
verschwinden wie es einige von euch
eventuell schon mitbekommen haben gibt
es in dieser folge einige soundprobleme
geil micro hat komplett verschließen im
laufe dieses videos werden die ein
bisschen schlimmer also wird sehr sehr
synchron teilweise ich versuche das hier
schon seit zwei stunden im schnitt so
ein bisschen auszugleichen aber trotzdem
schon mal entschuldigungen falls mein
mund oft nicht zu dem passt was gesagt
wird wir liegen auf jeden fall auf
supply boxen das heißt da schauen wir
jetzt auch mal rein
das ganze ist jetzt natürlich neuanfang
hierdurch spielt das heißt wir müssen
uns erst mal noch so ein bisschen in
krippen sachen aussuchen was sammeln et
cetera dabei es wird achten dass wir nur
acht plätze haben das heißt er wird
sieben von acht habe ich schon vor ich
habe die waffen das hier ist der kreis
in dem müssen wir uns aufhalten
das männerteam leute okay ich glaube ich
gehe tatsächlich mal zu meinem team
leuten die scheint ja nicht allzu
beschlüssen zu sein wenn die bis jetzt
sind wir hier gerade hören konnte wurde
einfach das nicht weggeschnitten so eine
audioaufnahme programme adobe audition
falls sich immer mit dem fehler
auskennen oder weil es ihr und dem
behebt dass das irgendwie ab und zu mal
ein paar wörter weg schneidet dann bitte
gerne nicht kommentare schreiben und
jetzt geht es weiter und das tut mir
wirklich leid
haha körper schritt rucksack ok ko louis
vitton ist also hier liegen wirklich
unfassbar viele supply boxen ich weiß
nicht ob die in jeder
runde neuem runterfallen weil also die
orte an denen die liegen das sind hoch
hallo dass die schiffe nicht so geil
[Musik]
wer sind meine teamkameraden es gibt nur
noch zehn verbleiben des quads das heißt
unser team ist gar nicht mal so
beschissen mit dabei wir drei sind auf
jeden fall noch alle am leben
was man auf jeden fall in dem spiel
anscheinend ja nicht kann ist bauen und
ich bau eigentlich recht gerne warum
glaubst du da so geduckt hinterlassen
dass auch dass der times square also
keine ahnung was da hinten abgeht
hier vorne stehen auch sowas ist dass
hier leute das sind bäume sieht ja mal
enorm groß so sich ein bisschen aus wie
bacon hier unten stehen karen sind das
hier respawn minuten jetzt auch noch
hier anscheinend sind wir denn hey wir
sind zumindest mitten in dem ding was
sind das hier versorgungs ab wo chance
auf hochwertige beute ja mädels was ist
jetzt hier planen also ich weiß nicht ob
ich hier der anführer der truppe binde
weil ich ja auch als erstes meine person
aussuchen durfte oder auch okay die
anscheinend ist er da hinten anführer
1996 hey da bin ich auch geworden also
hier liegen auch nur komische sachen es
hier was drin sie geil kommen die nehme
ich sie jetzt also einen grün roten
pfeil die muss gut sein es gibt nur noch
sechs verbleiben des quads um mein score
ist eins davon nur wenige minuten später
man deshalb auch gemeinde 26
ich hab' ich habe levelaufstieg probiert
hat gehört juckt mich einen scheißdreck
so kleinem ist hatte ja danke für deinen
support auf jeden fall meine damen und
herren haben meinen rücken news neues
spiel neues machen wir so nah ich werde
jetzt auf jeden fall mal wieder mit
meinen freunden hier zusammen landen
also mit meinen sportkameraden mich
neben den auf jeden fall erstmal schnell
alle sachen wenn irgend eine waffe zu
beginn kommt man selbst schuld alter
weiß hat er habe ich mir geredet hier
ja so sehe ich das auch nicht mehr hier
sachen raus können ja blöde sachen sie
war startete der check in slate man ich
wusste sorry ich geh dann mal an der
stelle würde ich das heutige video ipex
legions mit lukas auch beenden ganz ganz
viele leute oh mein gott ich bin level 3
ich habe unfassbar viele berichte über
dieses spiel gelesen und auch unfassbar
viele streamer wie zu beginn schon
gesagt ninja tief im monte ganz ganz
große leute auf twitter haben gesagt
pack dlc packs legions ich kann den
namen nicht mal dieses spiel ist lassen
neue for tonight das neue beste battle
royale spiel weil sie halt verschiedene
möglichkeiten haben wie beispielsweise
tote teamkollegen wieder zu beleben oder
auch im stream am modus sehen es gibt
das sind alles sachen die mich nicht
interessieren weil ich echte relativ
scheiße bin wenn euch dieses video hier
allerdings gefallen hat und ihr wollt
dass ich mich ein bisschen mehr mit
diesem spiel auseinandersetze vielleicht
auch privat ein bisschen spiele das
ganze ein bisschen besser kennen lernen
das gerne mal einen daumen hoch da
schreibt mir gerne die kommentare seit
er vor neid ex legends oder keins von
beiden also kann ja auch sein und ich
glaube auch dass viele form einer
community wirklich gar nichts zocken
abonniert mal einen kanal
[Musik]